oh this is a good one Hanna de Vries
I actually think of busy I've thought
about this [ __ ] already you knock on the
door to the bathroom if someone's in
there once that's it because nobody has
ever wanted to hang out in a [ __ ]
public bathroom longer than they've
needed to be so if I'm in there for and
I'm serious
35 minutes I'm [ __ ] my brains out
you don't [ __ ] come on hey
stuff is coming out of my [ __ ] dude
find another restroom or [ __ ] your pants
let me be I got here first
trust me I don't want this to be
happening more than you don't want this
to be happening this is funny actually
because it kind of it didn't backfire
but this is how someone learns I went to
go lock the door and I noticed that the
lock wasn't really that much of a good
lock if you really tried you could open
the door but I was like look I'll lock
it as long as it goes if somebody tries
to open it they'll see it's locked and
they're not gonna try to break it down
cuz they don't work for SWAT so I'm
there sitting down doing mmm business
and I hear a jiggle at the door and a
knock and I say I'm in here even though
I don't need to cuz the goddamn door was
locked and then I hear the jiggle again
and I'm like well this [ __ ]
gonna make this door open if he really
tries to do that and again I say hey I
don't know what you want me to tell you
but I'm busy and I'm in here then it
happens again and I get mad I get mad
because this person isn't understanding
that I'm not throwing my 25th birthday
party in this coffee bean bathroom with
piss all over the floor so then one last
time they jerked the door and this is by
the way not long enough they're giving
me between the jiggles and sure enough
the lock comes undone oh oh and right
then I go from angry to zero angry I
couldn't
be more relaxed if I were sleeping and
I'm common [ __ ] dude I'm as calm as a
[ __ ] typewriter okay they don't have
emotions the anger that I had is
realized into the love and excitement
that this person's gonna have to see me
with my pants around my ankles and my
[ __ ] privates on display while I'm
unloading and in walks a [ __ ]
twelve-year-old and I go oh that's funny
that's funny Lord that is funny and I
mean Lord this singer